AJ flack the head coach of the Gophers
our Gophers joining his Continental Tire
Coaches Corner House the boys today
coach boys are elite getting ready to go
out to the practice field you having us
on the show all right when you saw the
big reveal last night
8th in the ranking no but your reaction
the reaction was really positive just in
general that we're very fortunate we're
very humbled to represent the University
of Minnesota the great state of
Minnesota and all of our fans and alum I
think that's really important when
you're getting national attention and
and on a show like that for a half-hour
and and a lot of the show has to do with
the University of Minnesota so very
positive and and how we are able to
represent the University at our state
did you think you were going to get
ranked higher I don't think there was
any expectation to be honest with you I
think this team has really stayed away
from that all year we've talked about it
we've walked them through it they've
been preparing this as January and to be
honest I don't think anything shocks
this football team you know successful
people and successful teams are usually
not shocked by the success they have or
what other people think of them because
they prepare they've been preparing for
it and the pressure comes along with
that they've been preparing for that
pressure for a long time so I don't
think anything shocks this football team
they just got to continue to get better
this is a one game championship season
against Iowa they've been incredibly
focused on one week at a time type
mentality all year and that's why you're
there in this position the only reason
why they're in this position so there's
nothing that we have to change at this
point except just be better today than
we were yesterday but you know that the
inevitable question comes about that the
letdown you have this emotional win one
of the great wins in the program's
history and now you go to Iowa how do
you tell your kids even though they know
it and you know it not to have a letdown
against Iowa well this team is not built
for any let downs you know the game of
football that's why you play you just
never know what's going to happen
there's a lot of people who probably
didn't think we were gonna be able to
beat Penn State I think since week four
people have been that been saying that
to us well yeah but they haven't played
so and so yeah but they haven't played
so and so and oh they just beat this
team can they come back and beat this
team now and and we've not ignored all
of that we've listened to all of that
because I you know as with young people
they only have them for two hours a day
you know technically when you look at
the actual timesheets right you have
them for about two hours where you can
really influence them every other hour
of the day is spent outside through
social media the media other people that
talk to him so the message that you give
them has got to be very clear and very
direct and it's got to be able to take
all that outside noise bring it inside
process it and let your culture build to
spit it back out and hopefully the right
way but this team has taken a one-game
approach and that's all they're gonna
continue to do I mean yesterday's
Tuesday practice was the best Tuesday
practice we've had and that's all I can
continue to ask of our players is they
just keep changing their best
he's BJ Fleck the head coach of the
Minnesota Golden Gophers they've got
Iowa coming up this weekend
did you go to the combine after you were
at the Northern Illinois right I was yep
okay and then you were undrafted a free
agent but did you go to the combine no I
wasn't good enough to get invited in to
come behind I had the ability to have a
guy by the name of Michael Turner on our
football team at Northern Illinois and
there was a lot of us have benefited
from that because every NFL team showed
up to our pro day watch Michael Turner
and then you get one chance and one
chance only to impress people and all
you got to do is impress one team and I
guess the 49ers felt sorry for me so
they brought me in were you a possession
receiver PJ I was I think I had close to
200 catches in my career and I think
probably a hundred and ninety of them
were for first downs so that that's kind
of what my mo was did you get into a
game with the Niners preseason I did oh
yeah preseason games first were played
against played in one I call it real
game played in one field in my first
year against the New England Patriots
and I'm sure Tedy Bruschi remembers me
hitting him coming down which I have a
picture of in my office of it but I
guarantee you he did not feel it nor did
he never remember me but I remember
Tedy Bruschi that speech after the Penn
State game though that's pretty good
stuff do you script anything or is that
just this is how I feel some is not
scripted some is scripted based on the
exact message I want to be able to give
them from the whole week there's a lot
of thoughts and ideas that come along to
you all through the week and you've got
you
got 30 seconds to capture every heart
string in that room somehow some way and
that's your last chance to be able to
get them to believe in something bigger
than themselves they prepared all week I
don't think I've ever said anything that
allowed us to win a win a game ever
before a game I've got some great
pregame speeches that we've gotten blown
out so but I think it was a culmination
to bring in that whole week together
about the diamonds and how diamonds are
formed and you know pulling the diamond
out of the coal that they just wrote
what pressures done for their life on
this Black Rock and they'll put it in a
band and overnight it turned to a
diamond so I think something like that
just kind of gets them a little bit a
little bit just more ready a little bit
a little bit more focused and boom you
go out there and hope they can find a
way to get it done but sometimes it's
just a culmination of the entire week
great story so far coach have fun in
Iowa and we appreciate your time as
always
yeah thanks for having us on the show
row the boats came I'll go go first
thank you yeah and that's PJ flak for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]